my first moments in World War II first
instance of combat was against captain
and I got creamed kill me I'm still
trying to work out you know kind of
master this open-world game but I knew
that there were penalties to dying but I
was like you know screw this I'm going
back so I went and I hunted the same
captain down who was now stronger killed
me again and once more I got pissed
I found him again and by like the third
or fourth time of dying like an idiot he
became like a level-10 this is like me
off again first like five minutes of me
playing this game I screwed myself over
I couldn't stop it was like a addiction
I wanted the guy dead soon come on
legions and then four hours later there
he is
was like Nagre of the blood head clan
and at this point I'm able to combat him
and finally come out
what I started doing is in the biggest
strongholds I would start sneaking in
and I would just start turning them one
after another after another after
another until they were all basically in
in my camp and then I would do what I
needed to do to someone the Warchief and
then a lot of the time I was just able
to sit back let things happen they'll
all just turn on the Warchief I'm
basically getting killed a lot because I
think through these ghost powers I kill
everybody it's not really how that game
works but I was feeling pretty strong
this one moment a guy had killed me and
I was naturally so I went and found him
and I noticed there the character caves
nearby wrangled it hey girl
riding up on him I can see his back his
turn I'm like all this good I'm just
gonna bite his head off this is gonna be
awesome I get there
chomp but all of a sudden he does this
like roll thing you start stabbing the
category like crazy and then I like fall
off and get swarmed by his dudes totally
and it's because he has the monster
killer perk or whatever camp killed by
monsters would have been good to know
that
well I think I'm probably going to be
echoing an experience that a lot of
people have had in which I started the
game thinking I could take on this
entire economy myself and I couldn't I'd
I'd quite a lot and there was this one
particular captain that seemed to be in
my fights all the time and he just kept
slowly going up the ranks starting all
the way from the bottom and made use all
the way to the top I think he got to a
level of eighteen before I finally
managed to track him down and it forced
me to actually play stealthily so what I
did with this guy was instead of trying
to take him on in a group I followed him
halfway across the map to make sure that
he was alone there were no other all
patrols or anywhere nearby I went to the
top of a towel or I snipe his two
bodyguards with an arrow then I went
down and took him one on one it was a
great fight it was just me and him I
took my time we send him a couple of
times and then I and then I did the
killing blow and it felt really really
great but when it became really amazing
for me it was the very next captain that
I took on this guy somehow managed to
survive the fight and he came out and he
had like this big faceplate covering
half of his face and he was saying I
thought you got rid of me huh I'm not
that easy to kill and he took me one
again and killed me one last time and I
cursed a game and I also celebrated the
game for you know giving me that
excellent surprise the best thing
you know most I guess big Triple A games
nowadays do rely on you know set pieces
or you know a very particular way to get
through something so I'm really
appreciating the fact that more though
it just sets up these systems and allows
you to play in these sand boxes my
personal experience actually was I
didn't touch the main campaigns until
about four or five hours and so I didn't
get any of the cool powers that you
actually get when you start doing those
campaign missions so it was I had to
rely a lot on those base few skills that
you first bought and if it's exciting
because you know you can go out there
and just create your own stories around
this thing and it just shifts and
evolves to really interesting ways
things ways that I couldn't have
actually predicted when I first started
playing it
he was captain one and now he's like
just about become like a war chief to be
honest he's so close but he is just
impossible to kill look at all these
can't kill himself can't use any arrows
so if he eat so if he retreats even if I
use an arrow on his leg which is the
cool ability to like snake him stop
see a lot of times he he'll get so close
to health you can just about take him
out but you can use a arrow to stop him
from treating not this dude down he's a
tough one but I will kill him